ci passi tranquillamente inutile che
aspettive
[Musica]
questa qui era la stessa colonna sonora
che c'era quando i classe mia ai tempi
dovevano scegliere chi interrogare la
stessa cosa tutti ragazzi avessero video
sono farisei ci siamo su week che cazzo
è successo al mio mouse siamo su wii che
il problema è che il mio mouse è morto
mouse a merda ho riavviato ragazzi siamo
partiti con problemi al mouse perfetto
non ci avevo già giocato un episodio di
dewey caverà con i massi che era
arrivata la notte due
per chi non conoscesse sto videogame
obiettivo ragazzi è resistere finché non
arriva allora successiva quando arriverà
allora successiva ci sarà un altro
mostro in più eva ok sono però è rimasto
incastrato il mouse nuovo ma perché
aiuta ma perché rimane lasciatemi in
pace non funziona il mouse non
chiedetevi non so cosa sia successo non
ne ho la più pallida idea magari vinco
sto così arriva alla terza ora senza far
niente allora casuale ed è soprattutto
bello sapete quando in un horror quando
sociale nostre cose in un'ora
la prima cosa che sei pronta tinta che
ci roma è andata via ragazzi i nostri a
quando è andata via non è andata un
cazzo via chi è vero in un horror che è
successo c'è gesù gesù bambino armand
inter
peccato ho resistito un'ora e mezza
semplicemente guardando i piccioni è
stato fantastico
allora ragazzi non ho ben capito perché
né per come sia successa questa cosa per
ora come inizio da dio perfetto quanto
scommette ragazzi cos'è il pozzo c'è
[Musica]
salve c'è un bimbo piccolo ma sapete una
cosa ma chi cazzo te ne frega ho
resistito metà partita semplicemente
guardando in aria quindi se non quanto
scommettete che durò meno di prima è
questo che volevo dire perché astratto
sono incastrato fatemi uscire perfetto
grazie grazie grazie grazie veloce non
mi girano mi giro non vi diro nomi giro
non mi giro non vi dirò
senti flash junior che facciamo per i
cazzi nostri sei voglia perché di tanto
lo chiedo prima si dovrebbe sentire un
certo punto un gong
a un certo punto non so quando è il gong
li starebbe a significare che sono a
metà prima ci ha messo un anno e mezzo
fa ricordo rigore grazie ti può aprire
il cancello c'è solo alla una catena che
moderna riscavalcare tre volte no invece
non scavalchiamo andiamo con
tranquillamente a morire perfetto che si
scala
ecco il gong chiama metà ragazzi quando
c'è gong siamo a metà devo resistere
un'altra meta così che bello bellissimo
questo gioco amo un'ora vera dura tifosi
e vabbè ma minchia vecchia scuola mia
solo tanta gente ma alta [ __ ] dai di
due ore e mezza di dividere
cosa vuoi dalla vitamina b avendo
resistito quasi quanto prima è solo che
stavolta ho camminato che grave comunque
ragazzi l'obiettivo dovrebbe essere
almeno per questo episodio riuscire a
fare sta minkia lidi ora almeno questo
si è aperta una porta vi giuro che ho
sentito una porta aprirsi non so perché
[Musica]
s'è chiusa
sì chiusaforte ago glioni che è successo
ci passi tranquillamente inutile che
aspettive nostro fobia grazie bene anche
prima è però vabbè gentile hanno aperto
anche la porta gentilissimi fantasma non
so come ragazzi non sono molto infatti
molti fan culo
dove devo devo mettere una telecamera
sul mouse perché ogni volta non riesco a
ritrovarlo quando nicola sono ancora
vivo solo scherzando stavo scherzando
stavo scherzando che calmati ok metabo
metà ragazzi città che succede cosa c'è
d'aiuto perché intanto cioè bava in
volta sto tizio i tassi fa le canne no
no no non so perché ogni tanto di figlia
di girare strano prove che non mi giro
nomino non migliorano già entrati
societari valve l'ho preso sono fuori
sono fuori sono fuori cosa cazzo appena
fatto lega come mi sono salvato non lo
so non lo so non l'ho di uscire o mai
più
ok non riuscirò mai più quindi o vinco
vico appunto ok è no era l'ansia
cos'è
ma è ammalata la maremma ladra cosa era
marco la chiave sentito ed ha dato una
regolata per cortesia che regalo quanto
lo quanto odio madonna che è insieme
bambino più bambina più mio zio vuoi
mettere anche lui della gente che
risorge dal terreno e ha mancato le
pappe servivo sorpresa ragazzi prima ero
morto molto molto prima 15 sono in
dirittura sembrano 80 per cento ma nella
mia situazione e russo arrivo quella di
così non ci arrivo
e invece no seriamente regate culo
questa con questa veramente andata di
culo esprime prima sono morto così cioè
non so come ho fatto sopra vi è farlo e
io parlo sandy [ __ ] quando stata
stormi chiari 45 minuti che sono vivo
quanto nuovo sopravvivere fammi capire
ai scatta maledizione no veramente
regalo 12 ore
erba torri deficiente da è mica non hai
mai corso
veramente sto tizio qua è una roba
improponibile valente mia nonna e corre
più cos'è non lo voglio sapere non la
voglio vedere non la voglio toccare non
lo so ma bella tocco l'ho presa e l'ho
presa sono vivo bene perfetta la
maschera di v per vendermi ha niente di
più o se si è onesti sono in traguardi
da vero uomo
mica la figlia no perché io c'è dietro
tutto un bordello destra volta ho
provato a vincere e ho perso questa
volta solo sempre perdendo quindi per me
è proprio una vittoria a livello di
autostima dai ragazzi sono la terza ora
in che è durata un'ora vera
tanto per essere chiari per ora è lo
bello questo mi piace questo qui qui a
rigoni dhabi golf rete in italiano
significa abbiamo bisogno di un frigo
più grande spiegami quale minchia il
senso di avere un frigo grande in questo
videogame non spiegano quindi ragazzi
l'obiettivo di questo di questa questa
ora qui sarà andare all'ikea a trovare
un frigge mia ragazza arrivata alla
terza ora incredibile sorpreso benissimo
impossibile
perché ogni volta che iniziano nuova ora
c'è un nuovo nemico quindi adesso ci
dovrebbe essere un nuovo nemico che
prima non avevo visto il problema è che
dovrebbero annunciare all'inizio solo
che all'inizio stavolta invece nel
nemico hanno detto che abbiamo bisogno
di un frigo più grande e io che cazzo me
ne vo del frigo che cazzo evolve ma poi
superato il ponte si sentivano ali tate
nelle orecchie va magari anche noti
mobbing continua muoverti perché muoviti
[ __ ] non ve si muove non si muove
starà fermo che doveva aveva la porta è
ma porca è bravo che avrà un perfetto
perfetto professor ivo sapevo cosa vuol
dire chi si sta sollevando il terreno
sbagliarmi aver clonato eve anche
l'altra volta era
era così si rinnova lui ogni volta c'è
sempre bisogno di spiderman sta finendo
la carica e le candele crudeli più se in
volte sei tu colori non c'è manco
bisogno del freccia rossa cioè lui va di
suo
grazie per non aver chiuso la porta a
questo l'ho apprezzato se si può fare un
deal arriviamo alla fine in qualche modo
io vi do qualcosa tipo il mio pene
cos'è sta roba è una tomba anzi più
tombe un cimitero chiamassi cimitero non
volevo profanare la tomba della nonna
che cadono credimi veramente non avevo
un cazzo da fare solo che lo viste non
ci incazziamo è quello hanno fatto
niente eh vabbè zio però era quello il
nuovo nemico sicuro per questa cosa non
l'ho vista però proprio voglia di
avvicinarmi anziché soffrendo coraggio e
vado a vedere chi è che voglio vedere
voglio vederlo ecco siete pronti lega
giusto per questo non è lui o non è lui
che la nato sta e va a porta è ma porca
eva le posso ricordare cosa faccio non
sono morto che culo mi fai vedere il
tipo di prima che io voglio vedere non
l'ho visto eccolo sono curioso solo per
capire
non so page 1 ragazzi la prevedere un po
come la prova fatto le 3 di notte spero
nei prossimi giorni di riuscire a fare
le 4 piano ci arriveremo a una fine
spero che vi sia preceduto ragazzi cose
che se vi è piaciuta esso tuo commento
non mi piace anche a pagina di facebook
che come nei video tratta l'estizione se
ne sono resi rischiate riuscirvi il
diavolo pro serino dell'area